october is domestic violence awareness
month and sadly it's just an epidemic in
southern nevada and the number of women
seeking help has just increased over the
last year and there are several local
non-profit organizations dedicated to
helping victims one is unshakable their
mission is slightly different good day
las vegas anchor heather mills has more
tonight
i tell people there's four steps to a
full recovery the first one is the
rescue
residency
the
therapy
and then we're the rest of it so we
really guide women
as they are transitioning back to a
career debbie isaacs found it unshakable
five years ago to help women recovering
from trauma domestic violence human
trafficking homelessness and substance
abuse in that time they've helped more
than 250 women get back on their feet we
put together 12 workshops that focus on
business acculturation
overcoming
you know a lack of self-confidence
and
life skills for financial independence
according to the nevada coalition to end
domestic and sexual violence there were
more than 24 thousand calls for help in
2020. people i think always go why don't
they just leave but the truth is you
can't leave right if you're not if they
don't have the ability to support
themselves or their children that's
where training and education comes into
play isaac says they help women find
their career passion to make a permanent
life change counseling always has you
looking backwards our career coaching
has you looking forward heather mills
live local now